and game number three
lucas giolito brings the socks out
first time 22-5 over a 27-game stretch
in a decade for the chicago white sox
that was off speed high in the sky right
hand side nomar mazzara for route number
one
after a fastball fouled off this 3-2 is
hit in the ear luis robert
for round number two
up the middle second base madrigal is
there and a one hopper
jay quarter rizzi in his time with the
twins has been good
and now they've got anderson in a
rundown
and adrianza with the tag with the ball
in his bare hand
and so strike him out throw him out with
anderson aborting
a stolen base attempt two and two to
jose abraham
and he got him with a fastball let's see
if rosario can get it going here in the
second 2-2 pitch a fly ball into right
field deep going back mazzara on the
track at the wall that's gone
a home run on a change-up rosario
homer's out to right
and the twins finally take an early lead
in chicago it's a one-nothing twins lead
in the second
doing it for the first time in the
postseason there's a strike three
foul a foul tip avila hangs on for the
first out
and that'll get buffed into the plate
with rosario still at first
high fly center field sounded good
robert back at the wall and it's gone a
home run for byron buxton
over the fence outside the park
that's a huge hit right there for buck
this time he made it a little bit easier
on himself hit it over the wall and
get to trot around the bases and the
twins like that leads three to nothing
so abril struck out his first time that
ended the first inning
lead the american league hits and runs
driven in jim rice
yaz lou gehrig abreu trying to be the
fourth
jose tart left field and quickly out of
here bring
him home it's 3-1 frank you want a
statement game that's a start
flight number 79 leaves in a hurry and
jose abreu
with his 16th home run of the season
it's now 3-1 minnesota here in the
fourth two down
there's james mccann otto keeps looking
at that finger
oh he's going to call him out now it's
gotten to the point or at least the
catcher
you can see his middle fingers quivering
because of the discomfort and i think
he's going to have to come out of this
game
that's that's a shame jake odorissi is
very frustrated
he's coming back after a long absence he
wants to help his ball club stay in this
race
he can't do it now an interesting
situation with cody stacia coming in
91 of the belt swing of the miss dashak
gets the strikeout two or two from lucas
and that comes back to giolito
and that is out number one alex avila
in complete self-defense wrapped that
back to the mouth
quick pitch he struck him out change up
he wasn't going to mess with looking at
cruz
flexing his wrist that's a ground ball
fielded by
donaldson and on target to sono one away
what a job he did tonight and duffy on
10 pitches
has a one two three seventh inning
big chopper and monkatta is gonna have
to play it on only to first
there's a ground ball but certainly not
double play caliber
donaldson to second one down rosario
there it was see you later two down
and that'll bring up chanel this will be
a big insurance run right here if you're
able to add on
3-1 swimming a blind ball center field
in deep
back it goes robert on the track at the
wall that's going to home run
cenote and dead center
an 8th inning two out two run homer and
the twins take a commanding 5-1
lead in chicago
97 in a good spot a strikeout that's a
good start right there
and another 97 mile per hour heater
for another strikeout
the twins bullpen tonight perfect
the twins pitchers and the knight
retiring the final 18.
chicago batters and the twins magic
number to wrap up a playoff spot
is down to four